hi my name is david ferreira and i live
in the state of new hampshire home of
the first primary in the presidential
election Dixville notch where the first
votes are tallied in the presidential
election Mount Washington home to the
world's worst weather we think that I
live in the southern town of Amherst New
Hampshire named after Lord Jeffrey
Amherst the British general in the
French and Indian War and emerged New
Hampshire is not the only town named
after or Jeffrey there's also Amherst
mass and Amherst New York if I were
given a free ticket to anywhere in the
world I would pick heat Japan an
archipelago in the North Pacific Ocean I
would pick Japan because of its great
technology like Assam oh the humanoid
robot from Honda also Sony the creators
of the Walkman the DVD player and the
cd-rom and I would take a ride on the
bullet train the fax is trained in the
world to see how fast it really goes I
would also see a martial arts
demonstration and a sumo wrestling match
seeing how big the men really are and i
would go to Mount Fuji and a baseball
game since we have so many American
players that are Japanese as far as the
knowledge goes I don't know how I cram
it all into my head all I know is that
I've been entertaining my family with it
since up since I was born when I was
four I memorized all the presidents and
at a very young age I had these blocks
these six sided box that had animals
numbers and letters on each side of them
my parents always quiz me on them and I
always got them right because I
memorized them as far as geography
knowledge goes I've been fascinated from
about to that's when I picked up my
first map I was fascinated by the colors
of the map on a political map and then
as time went on I slowly realized it was
our plan and then I tried to find facts
and cultures and all other geographic
superlatives about these countries and
now i am here going to Washington DC I
don't know how I did it but I did and I
have a burning desire to win
you